sierra and diego i want to start with
you of course monsei and caesar they had
some romance and they had some
roadblocks in season four how do you
feel about how their romance played out
this season and are they together in
your mind yeah i would say
they're not together in my mind i think
they left off
on great terms as friends and
potentially something could develop
later down the line once they both have
their figured out more so seizure at
least watch your language uh in season
four we have intense arguments you know
where she's telling caesar i'm not going
to risk my life for you i'm not going to
put my life and my future in jeopardy
and i think that was something that
as an audience as a fan of the show not
even like playing a character on the
show um i was really waiting for that
moment for for monte
to really stick up for herself and put
herself first be a little selfless and
uh care more about her future than than
some
teenage boy named cesar diaz it's so
funny too because i thought the same
thing i'm like
wow like you really see
how selfish caesar is this is
i see a future
am i in it
if i'm lucky
we both are but at the same time like i
feel like they still have so much love
for each other regardless because
they've been in each other's lives for
so long so i think like you said they're
on the same page now and they both know
that they need to figure out who they
are as individuals but they're both like
we'll see what happens in the future
okay it's all love okay now now speaking
of the future jessica and jason uh we
gotta talk about ruby and jasmine ruben
martinez
will you go to prom with me
is there chamoy
like i
forget it's a date
[Music]
are they gonna figure it out and stay
together what do you see for them in
their next chapter i see a few things i
feel like it could go one or two ways
like i could see them you know being
together forever and like getting
married and having kids and then i can
also see the speaking for jasmine that
she has more to offer than being the
other half of jasby you know feel like
it's she she's such a selfless person
and she showed that throughout the
season the series that i think it's her
turn to kind of put herself first too
and you know focus on her education and
what other opportunities there are for
her i mean she's taking care of her dad
too so not going to berkeley was a big
blow for her
and i
i i selfishly like want to see them
together forever yeah because jasmine's
so good for ruby right like
ultimately like i feel like there's so
much more than just like this
infatuation between them like it's like
this friendship and like this
equal match of like drama and con
they're they're like each other's max
drama and and comedic why so it's just
like i'd love to i i feel like i see old
like hispanic couples
and i'm like y'all were once
i'm wearing a rocking chair julio i want
to go to you of course
a shocking and heartbreaking moment in
in season four of course
saying goodbye to oscar
[Music]
oscar
oscar
[Music]
what did you make of that it's hard to
say this but i i did like to see that
there you know there are consequences
for choices and even though he was doing
his best to
correct those things in his life his
past caught up to him and um i don't
want to say this in like as harsh words
but i hope that it is a reminder that uh
you know these things do happen and it's
not a joke it's not a it's not a game
that you can just go in and you know
frivolously just you know hang out in in
that life if you're really gonna do it
you gotta own up to the consequences if
they catch up to you
i wanna know a little bit about the
final day
on set i want you to be honest were
there tears what was that daylight
oh you know what we've only done this in
uh in one season before we shoot the
last scene of the show
on the last uh day yeah so it was so
it was
perfect yeah perfectly well timed and
bittersweet we all got to rap together
yeah yeah and uh i think everybody was
there if they weren't working that day
they showed up just to say bye and it
was yeah it's bittersweet uh you know
saying saying adios to uh i remember it
i remember it being a night shoot and
like as badly as i wanted to like cry
and be sad i also just wanted to go
[Laughter]
i think it was because there was all of
us like the parents were there like
everybody
was there that it was hard to kind of be
sad because we just have such a good
time together that we were all just like
laughing like the parents were getting
in trouble in the house because they
were being too loud while we were
filming it was like you guys aren't
actually drunk
they also like
you would think there'd be tears and
stuff and i mean there kind of was what
they actually had to say kicked us out
like right they really did right they
clubbed us at 2
and a.m because they they kicked they
were like guys it's four a.m it's we
have to we have to wrap it up i think
genuinely like
i don't know if i'm speaking for
everyone but it wasn't that sad because
it's like it's like leaving your like
aunt's house it's like you know you're
coming back right right like it's sad to
like leave on thanksgiving like oh bye
i'll see you guys but it's not like
goodbye forever right it's like i'll see
y'all and look here we are we're all so
close it's like saying goodbye to our
characters but definitely not them right
yeah yeah of course okay so did anybody
take anything from wardrobe or oh we all
did
we just want to know about everybody
in season one
i stole my cash chair like my entire cat
because everybody was like yeah like
take your cash to the just the back of
it she took the whole check i was like
delirious at like 4am and i was like all
right i'll take my cash drag
i really wanted juanita the the thick
gnome
but they hit her from me i couldn't find
her
you earned juanita after all thank you
i think so too they would not budge on
it i just haven't i'm like i know you're
about to steal her yeah i just have ruby
sneakers because i'm not really a
collared shirt type of guy
as you see he's a mesh type of guy i
have jasmine's earrings
oh you got to have the who i had to have
my hooves
yeah i had like a hoodie like i feel
like monster wore so many hoodies i
wanted jamal's remember those like
cheetah slippers yeah you had those bugs
those were cute i was i wanted jamal's
room room i was like his new room new
room i think i took the little pac-man
thing don't take nothing out my room
never seen it i seen a picture of
diego's sleep in jamal's bed what are
you doing i would always sleep on that
my last question because i'm getting the
wrap we're so excited about the spin-off
who wants to reprise their role and who
will make an appearance
we don't know anything about it we have
nothing to do
would you be down for an og on my block
movie
uh the movie yeah yeah
only if there's gnomes in it
i mean there's two years in between
there yeah yeah we could have did like a
senior trip
that would have been fun fingers crossed
that we'll get more
i thought thank you so much thank you so
much